Now I'd like to introduce you to today's
featured presenter, Michael Bennon.
Michael Bennon is the Managing Director
at the Stanford Global Project Center
developing new initiatives to the GPC and
managing their student programs
in industry affiliations.
Mike's research areas of interest for
the center and
work experience are in public
sector finance, infrastructure and
real estate investment and
project organization design.
Mike served as a Captain in the US Army
and US Army Corps of Engineers for
five years, leading engineer units,
managing projects, and planning for
infrastructure development in the US,
Iraq, Afghanistan, and Thailand.
Mike received a Bachelor's Degree
in Civil Engineering
from the United States Military Academy
at West Point and received an MSCE and
MBA from Stanford University.
And by the way, if you like what you're
hearing today in Mike's presentation,
you may also be interested in taking
his Stanford graduate course on
Global Project Finance that's being
offered this upcoming winter quarter.
Mike will talk more about
the class in a moment.
But we want to flag that enrollment is
currently open until December 11th.
So feel free to visit the SCPD site to
learn more about the course and enroll.
And now I'll turn it over to Mike.
>> So I've got a lot of material to cover
in a short period of time, but first,
I'll just take a couple minutes to plug
my research program in the course.
So I work at
the Stanford Global Projects Center.
So we're an interdisciplinary
research center at the university.
And we kind of work between
the different department silos at
the university to conduct
interdisciplinary research.
And our topic is on innovation and
infrastructure finance and development.
So we like to frame our research program
as covering a broad spectrum and
on one end of that spectrum we
have institutional capital.
Let me see if I can enhance this, okay.
So on one end of that spectrum we
have institutional allocations to
infrastructure, so an institutional
investor such as a pension fund or
sovereign wealth fund.
More recently, some of these institutional
investors have created allocations to
the asset class, so we do research on
that trend within the industry and
the risks associated with
infrastructure allocation.
On the other end of that spectrum,
we do work on government policies and
practices and infrastructure development.
So some of these include
procurement practices,
what I'll be talking a little bit
about today, in the United States.
And other topics include public policies
in and around infrastructure development.
And finally we do case based research
on the projects in which that
institutional capital is
invested in infrastructure.
And lastly, we also have a program on
innovation and infrastructure development,
and the trend of cities towards
participating in the digital economy.
Now, for a quick overview of my
course which is starting in January.
So, Global Project Finance really
covers that whole spectrum of
infrastructure development and
project risk.
So part of the course is focused on
the basics of project structuring and
development from the concepts
we'll talk about today.
And then we also have modules
on project risk assessment and
then a large module on
infrastructure investment.
So most of our class sessions
involve a topical lecture by me and
then a guest presentation
from an industry executive,
the head of a public procurement
agency for infrastructure or
an infrastructure fund manager,
or a project developer,
a financial advisor or
even the manager of a pension portfolio.
The course objectives are generally
to prepare students for
a career in project finance and
infrastructure development.
And for our assignment for the course
we develop a financial model and
a risk assessment for
an infrastructure project,
and we develop components of it
over the course of the quarter.
This year its going to be
a toll road investment.
So on to what project finance is.
So project finance involves the ring
fenced financing of an infrastructure
asset based on the microeconomics
of the project itself,
as opposed to the sponsor balance sheet or
the city, or government's balance sheet.
So infrastructure projects,
they have a few distinct tasks
that are required to complete them and
manage them over the long term.
So they have to be designed, built,
financed, and then operated and
maintained.
Under traditional
infrastructure procurement,
the government essentially hires
companies to complete all of those tasks,
or uses internal staff to complete some
of them but it generally procures them
separately and manages the interfaces
between those contracts.
Under a project finance or
as it's also referred to as
a public-private partnership or P3,
essentially the government procures
one contract for a private partner to
complete all of those paths and
then manage the interfaces between them.
The governments usually use
this procurement model,
the prime driver is to transfer the risk
of infrastructure development to
that private sector partner.
So infrastructure projects are some
of the most risky enterprises that
governments undertake.
I like to bucket the risks associated
with infrastructure development
into three buckets.
So one, it can of course take much
longer to build than expected and
go way over budget and
those are commonly correlated.
It can also cost more to operate and
maintain the asset than the government
originally forecasts and
then finally, for projects that are funded
by a user fee, such as a toll road,
there can be lower demand than what
the government originally expected.
So that could cause a lack
of funding in the future.
So governments as I mentioned generally
use this procurement model to
transfer risk to the private partner
in developing and maintaining an asset.
So there's a few criteria that
we recommend for governments or
project sponsors to consider when
they're assessing a potential
project as a potential for
project finance.
And so the first of those is simply scale.
Larger projects generally
entail more risk, so
this procurement model is really mostly
suited to larger infrastructure projects.
The second factor is general project risk,
so has the sponsor done one of these
projects before, how did that go,
is this a particularly unique project
where there might be significant
ONM risk or construction cost risk.
The third factor is flexibility.
So because of these, project finance
generally entails a longer contract.
Generally if there's a need for
flexibility due to technology change or
other factors, this procurement
model might not be a good fit for
that because it's generally used for
longer term contracts.
And then finally,
the last factor is innovation.
So this procurement model because it
combines construction and operation and
maintenance into one contract,
there's opportunities for innovation for
the contractor that's building the asset
because they have to both build it and
operate and maintain it in the long term.
So that means they might make decisions
during construction to optimize for
lifecycle costs, instead of just
the initial cost to build the asset.
So this slide shows the many parties
involved in a complex infrastructure
project and
how they relate to one another.
Under a project finance structure.
So generally a special purpose vehicle or
an SPV is created with the sole purpose
of building and
maintaining the infrastructure project.
The SPV will have equity investors,
it will arrange for
financing to build the project, and
then it will also have contracts with
the many contractors, and or
operators needed to build the project.
It'll also have a project development
agreement with the sponsoring government.
So, onto our topic for today.
So to get straight to the point,
this procurement model isn't used
in the United States at the same
rate as it's used in other
developing economies globally.
So I like Canada and Australia as good
comparators to the US because they're
also large land mass developed
economies and federal democracy.
And this chart shows the usage of this
procurement model in Australia and
Canada, both in terms of
the capital attracted, and
the number of projects compared to the US.
So it's pretty clear that it's used
much less in the United States which by
population of course has a much larger
economy than Canada and Australia.
The question is why hasn't this model
picked up in the United States.
Well I think this chart shows
that it's not due to demand.
So this chart shows all
of the transportation and
social public-private partnerships that
had been procured in the United States,
and it's sourced from
an industry publication.
So the start of each of these bars
indicates the start of the procurement
process from the sponsoring government.
So, typically when a government
pursues one of these projects,
it starts by issuing a request for
qualifications, or RFQ,
to potential companies that
would compete for the project.
The end of this bar is commercial close,
or when the government effectively
signs a contract with that
infrastructure developer to then go and
finance and then build the project.
For the red bars, the end of the bar is
commercial close, or the contract signing.
For the grey bars,
its when the project was cancelled.
So I think this charts
indicates a couple of trends.
One is that demand for
this procurement model in
the United States is certainly increasing.
You can kind of see that by the start
of procurement is kind of accelerating
over time.
What's also very clear from
this chart is that successful
procurements are not being
completed at that same rate.
So in general, this procurement model does
take a little bit longer to procure in
the United States when you compare with
other developed economies, like Europe.
But what makes the US particularly unique
is the prevalence of project cancellation.
So you can see a lot
of gray on this chart.
So this chart further illustrates
what I think is an explanation of
this trend in the United States.
So this shows a breakdown of
infrastructure spending, both by capital
projects, or spending for new
infrastructure, and operation maintenance.
It's also broken down by the federal
government, and then our state and
local governments.
So I think this chart debunks a bit
of a myth about US infrastructure.
So a lot of media reports have indicated
that part of the problem with US
infrastructure is essentially
that politicians don't prioritize
infrastructure enough
in the United States.
And this indicates to me that this
is only partially true, mainly for
our federal government.
State and local governments, on the other
hand, are actually increasing spending in
real dollars to infrastructure and they're
particularly increasing it to maintenance.
So there's been a big shift, essentially,
in responsibility in the United States
from spending primarily by
the federal government to spending
by state and local governments.
This slide indicates part
of my explanation for
why this procurement model of using
project finance hasn't picked up in
the United States as it has
in other developed economies.
So to explain this rather quickly,
this chart shows infrastructure
spending over time both on capital
projects and on maintenance projects.
And so we use an institutional explanation
for the unique circumstances of
infrastructure development in the United
States as it relates to project finance.
So essentially what I mean by that
is a lot of our institutions,
and by that I mean our public agencies for
developing and
maintaining infrastructure at
the state and local level,
were formed during very high levels of
spending by the federal government.
And most of that spending
was focused on capital cost.
Now federal spending is still primarily
oriented towards capital costs,
but the world that we exist in
in the United States is a much
different place than in
the decades following World War II
when heavy federal spending
was supporting capital costs.
And our public institutions
were essentially designed for
that world as opposed to the situation
that we're currently in with that
broad shift in responsibility towards
our state and local agencies.
So part of our explanation is that our
public institutions in the United States,
primarily at the state and local level,
aren't really designed to manage
procurements using project
finance which has to account for
all of the life cycle costs of an asset
as opposed to just capital costs which
are supported by the federal government.
So this is my last complex chart for
today, so
this is that same data on
public-private partnerships,
transportation and social
infrastructure broken down by state.
So the x axis shows the number of
projects that have been procured.
The size of each bubble is the relative
amount of capital that the state's been
able to attract using
this procurement model.
And then the y axis is
the average procurement time for
projects in that state.
Now I use this chart to
illustrate basically the power
of institutional change for
public agencies in developing a new
procurement model like project finance.
So every state that has procured more
than one of these projects, essentially
has undergone some form of institutional
change in its public agencies.
Just to highlight a few, so Texas, Florida
and Virginia have all created P3 offices
within their departments of transportation
with varying levels of autonomy.
Colorado has created the High Performance
Transportation Enterprise which procures
projects in its state.
Indiana created
the Indiana Finance Authority which has
procured all of its P3s.
And then the city of Long Beach
is a pretty unique example and
it's actually our case study for
this morning, has procured two of the last
three public-private partnerships in
California just by one city alone,
and we'll talk a little bit more about
that in a minute So none of these agencies
would be a kind of fully
autonomous alternative
procurement agency like those that have
been formed in Canada and Australia.
So I list a few here,
a couple in Canada and
a couple in In Australia that have
been created to kind of manage this
very different form of infrastructure
procurement within their states.
These are all states or
provincial agencies.
So, all of these agencies are different,
but
they share some common characteristics.
One is that they're not sector based,
so they report either to the treasury or
directly into the state executive.
All of them manage
infrastructure procurements that
are completed using project finance or
another kind of alternative structure for
an infrastructure project.
These agencies are really designed
to have the internal resources and
the capacity to manage those
alternative procurements as opposed to
traditional infrastructure,
which is very different.
They also all have an important
role in reporting.
Because project finance
involves a long-term contract,
reporting is a special importance
both on a programmatic level,
and these agencies issue specific
reports on their projects.
And so
to kind of explain the trend of Canada and
Australia adopting this procurement
model at a faster rate, which we talked
about earlier, all those projects were
procured by organizations like these.
So what to do about this
situation in the United States?
Well, we have a few
policy recommendations.
And these are specifically
relating to federal policy.
So federal support for
mega projects is especially important,
especially projects that cross state or
other institutional lines.
Lending support programs that are already
in place or that are ramping up for
project finance loans are also
a helpful policy program and
these are already in place.
Enabling project finance fact
projects to access the municipal bond
market is also a good federal policy.
Some of these are in place,
and others have been proposed.
More importantly, I think,
is the federal government's institutional
sport for state and local government.
It's especially important so
the Build America Bureau,
which is newly formed, and
the Transportation Investment Center.
These are both programs that help stage
your local government, transition
or use this procurement model and
they distribute eventually best practices.
Those are our strong initiatives.
And then perhaps most importantly, one
of my big federal policy recommendations
is to create programs that fund
projects based on the practices or
innovative programs as opposed to just the
economic benefits of the project itself.
So the new grant program at
the Department of Transportation,
the INFRA Grant program,
I think is a step in the right direction.
I think that program could be
significantly expanded to even provide
funding support for infrastructure
programs like the creation of
a new infrastructure agency as opposed to
just supporting an innovative project.
So now I'll spend a few minutes talking
about our specific case study for today.
This is the case of
the Long Beach Civic Center which is
currently under construction.
I really like this project because
it illustrates a lot of the concepts
that I've talked about in terms
of the project finance basis.
It illustrates some
procurement concepts for
how cities can use this procurement
model and it's a good case for
a lot of the topics that we'll
talk about in my course.
So this project is
essentially to tear down and
replace the city hall.
It's going to tear it down.
The project will build a new
city hall to replace it.
The project will also develop
a new headquarters for
the city's port authority,
a new library and a new public park.
Once that project is developed,
the company that's building it is going
to be responsible for operating and
maintaining the buildings themselves for
a 35- year concession.
The total financing costs for the project
were about just over $500 million.
So what made this project
a successful procurement?
It's still under construction currently.
Well, the reason the city was
replacing its city hall was
because back in 2005, the city determined
that it was seismically deficient.
The building was about 40 years old, and
it was rapidly decaying and the city
determined that they needed to replace
it because it didn't meet seismic code.
The city didn't replace it initially,
but they conducted some studies.
And in 2013, the city chose to start
pursuing a public-private partnership.
And I think there's a few reasons
that the city chose this procurement
model as opposed to traditional
infrastructure procurement.
One is that the first municipal building,
P3, in the United States was also
developed in the city of Long Beach.
So as a researcher on
institutional development within
the infrastructure industry,
I think that's an excellent trend, and
that the city that procured the second
project using this procurement model was,
of course, the city that had the first
use of this procurement model.
Another factor that led
the city to use this project
finance to develop this
project was that the existing
facility was deteriorating at a much
more rapid pace than the city expected.
So there was a real deferred
maintenance problem.
So when the city first came up with
the cost estimate to rehabilitate
the old building in 2006,
they came up with an estimate.
As they were considering options for
the redevelopment of the city hall, they'd
been escalating the cost to rehab the old
building at 5% in their
internal estimates.
When they reassessed the building in 2013,
their estimate they found
that an additional more
than $30 million of deferred maintenance
had occurred on the building.
So the building was deteriorating
at a much more rapid
rate than they originally expected.
The third factor for this project,
and probably the most important
in kind of driving the city to
use this procurement model,
is the city simply calculated their
annual cost to maintain the old facility.
So, they came up with an estimate
that they were spending around 12 and
half million dollars a year
on the old facility.
And the city essentially just went to the
market and said, we'll spend $12.5 million
a year and no more on the new facility,
in terms of an annual payment.
And the city said it would
index that to inflation.
So how did the city eventually
get a much larger project for
that same annual payment?
So instead of just replacing the city
hall, the project is going to build
a new port authority building,
a new library and a new city park.
Well, part of the factor there is
that the old facility was sitting
on a lot of unused public land.
So the developer of this project,
once they complete all of those other
facilities, they're going to be permitted
to develop some residential and
commercial real estate on some
of that unused public land.
So the city effectively used some
of that unused land to offset
the capital cost of
developing a new city hall.
One of the other important factors for
this project was a performance-based
maintenance requirement.
So the contractor that builds the new
facilities is going to be responsible for
maintaining them in the long term, and
there's specific performance
requirements in the contract.
I highlight a couple on this slide,
for example, elevators, and
elevators out for maintenance
was a big concern of city staff.
And so, there's a specific
requirement in the contract for
the contractor to essentially
repair elevators that are down for
maintenance quickly, and if they they
don't, the city's payments are reduced.
In fact, if enough elevators are out,
then the city
can deem part of some of the upper floors
of the city hall not available, and
does not pay rent effectively
on that part of the building.
The maintenance requirements also
have a handback requirement at
the end of that 35 year concession.
So essentially,
the Facility Condition Index, or FCI,
has to still remain 20% at
the end of that 35 year period.
So that essentially means that
the building will be 20% deteriorated.
To put that into context,
the old building,
which was about 40 years old,
had an FCI of 52%.
And the library,
the old library that's being replaced,
had an FCI of 73% at the time
the project started.
To put those numbers into perspective,
those are clearly in the tear down
territory for a public building.
And so, the city,
at the end of the concession period will
be able to inspect the facility to make
sure that it meets that FCI of 20%.
The last aspect of this that I wanted to
highlight was, the city was able to tailor
the contract based on the different
public agencies involved in the project.
So as I mentioned earlier, the city was
having a deferred maintenance problem, so
they transferred more of the maintenance
responsibility to the private contractor.
The port facility is also going to
be maintained by the contractor, but
the port didn't have the same maintenance
problem on its existing assets.
And it wanted to perform more of the basic
maintenance using its internal staff or
contractors.
And so,
for the port building, the contractor's
really going to be more responsible for
major maintenance and rehabilitation,
as opposed to minor maintenance.
The other, of course,
unique factor of this
project is because it's funded on
an annual availability payment.
The city effectively doesn't make
payments on the city hall or
library facilities until they're
kind of turned over to the city.
Well, that was my case and
topic for today.
I hope it was useful and if you're
interested in learning more about these
concepts, our website's
www.gpc.stanford.edu.
And it'd be great to turn it over for
some questions, thanks.
>> Mike, as need for
water infrastructure funding increases,
do you think bond funding, less than
$50 million, will be in higher demand?
Also, do you think bond financing and
community involvement,
community members participating
in bond financing, will increase?
>> Yeah, that’s a great question.
I definitely think that, of course,
as there’s increasing demand for
infrastructure, investment
in smaller projects.
Most of those projects and
most infrastructure generally is
going to use traditional procurement.
And, of course,
that could entail some bond financing, so
I do think that it’ll increase.
In terms of the other part of your
question, just focused on Project 5,
so this procurement model is
used in the water sector.
And there's also some other forms
of alternative procurement,
in which it would be used for
a long-term maintenance contract, but
there wouldn't necessarily
be private financing.
And so, I think those
procurement models will increase
as more water utilities kind of turn to
kind of long-term maintenance contracts.
In terms of project size,
as I mentioned, this procurement model
is generally used for smaller projects.
I put $100 million dollars as a good floor
just to illustrate
the complexity of the project.
Where there is an opportunity for
smaller projects is in project bundling.
So that would be a case in which multiple
utilities that require an investment
effectively bundle their
projects together,
and procure one contract for
all of the investments.
So that would be the real opportunity for
project finance for
those smaller projects.
>> All right, thanks, let's take another.
So we have a participant asking, are
certain types of infrastructure projects
more successful when using the P3 models?
And he's given the example of statistics
with toll roads, airports, etc.
>> Yeah, so in general,
I would say that the projects that
entail more risk are better
suited to this procurement model.
So a project such as a toll
road that has funding risks,
if there's not enough drivers for
the road that entails additional risk.
And therefore, this procurement model
is a strong fit for that sector.
Airports is interesting,
I mentioned the US is an outlier for
this procurement model,
and airports is the one
sector where the US is
probably the largest outlier.
So most airports that are in
other international developed
economies have been financed
using project finance.
And in those cases,
the remuneration for the investors and
the airport are essentially, of course,
the airline fees that use the airport.
But then also, things like parking or
rents from the vendors in the airport,
so there isn't necessarily
any single sector in which
this procurement model is
a particularly unique fit.
But in the US, at least,
it's mostly been used for
toll roads,
as I think the asker mentioned.
>> Right, so did these Canada or Australia
P3 agencies have any special process for
expedited environmental approvals?
You spoke about them in your presentation.
>> Yeah, so I don't think they
necessarily have a process for
going around traditional
environmental approvals.
They do have kind of the expertise to
manage the local environmental processes.
In procurement, so, essentially, to make
those assessments during procurement.
I also think they do some
programmatic level work.
So, just for example,
infrastructure in New South Wales
developed and maintains a 25 year
infrastructure plan for the state.
So that kind of long term perspective,
I think, can assist with, kind of,
environmental approvals and
planning by simply laying out
the actual need specifically.
>> Great, so
like staying in the global prospective can
developing countries an example,
like Indonesia immolate P3 approach with
the large projects that
you're representing here?
>> Yeah and then developing economies
actually use this procurement model
fairly often so that trend is more a
phenomenon of multilateral bank policies,
so several multilateral
lenders like the World Bank
require that project finance be used for
some of their infrastructure projects.
So developing economies can certainly use
this procurement model, it's been used in
Indonesia even for some small or
infrastructure project.
They're in for, more recently,
some very large project.
I guess the requirement really is
that in using project finance because
the investment is really based
on the project's economics and
not the balance sheet or
credit of the sponsoring government.
For this particular
model to be used is just
additional scrutiny on the project itself.
So in order for this to be used in
a developing economy, the government
there would simply have to adequately
appropriate funding for the project.
So in that way, project finance
can be almost a tool to create
additional scrutiny on the project itself,
to make sure that the project
economics and risks make sense.
>> Great, this one specifically is looking
at your case study that you presented.
Who were the equity and debt investors
in the Long Beach example, and
what guarantees did they have
against project cancellation?
Or else, another way,
who bore the development risk?
Yeah that's a really good question and
if you
may have noticed on my slide
showing the completed and cancelled
procurement there's a lot of development
risk, particularly in the United States.
To answer your question more specifically,
I believe the contractor for
Long Beach is an infrastructure
developer called Plannery
and so they would be the equity.
I believe they actually arranged private
financing, so a private loan for
financing the project,
that was just based on their assessment
of the best way to finance the project for
them.
In terms of development risk,
it is a considerable factor and
the companies that procure that
compete for these projects do
bear some development risk, mainly
because as you can imagine, the costs for
them to compete for the project and
develop proposals is quite high.
Not sure of the specifics for Long Beach
but I believe they included a stipend for
essentially if they cancel the project,
then the companies that were competing for
it get a small payment
to recoup their cost for
pursuing the project, and that's fairly
common for one of these procurements and
it's a good practice for governments
to incentivize competition I think.
>> Let's see, so P3's look very attractive
for long term projects until the many
states face a challenge of blended state
and local funding requirements as well
as moving much of maintainance
to operating budgets.
How do you suggest P2 success for
a blended funding model?
>> Yeah, that's a great question and
I think it certainly is a big factor.
You know, a great example of state and
local government I think
that are really tackling that challenge
would be Fargo, North Dakota, currently.
So they're currently procuring
a flood protection P3 and project and
they're really going through
the process between,
there's two states involved,
multiple municipalities.
And they're really going through
the process to determine who pays for
what and blending that funding.
So the answer in terms of multiply
funding sources, or funding coming
from different pots is essentially
through the project development process.
Those desperate agencies
have to come together.
Another good example might
Partnerships Victoria,
one of the agencies in Australia,
I mentioned.
So they have a practice that for
one of these complex procurements
they form a project board,
and partnership Victoria sits on that
board, but so does other agencies and
sources of funding that are involved
in the project in any way.
The board is how those
agencies communicate and
develop all the agreements necessary
to complete the procurement.
Thanks so much for
all these great questions.
Here's another one.
Considering this model is fairly new,
I'm wondering if there
any statistics on average
financial performance of the project
from each stakeholder's perspective.
There are some aggregates,
statistics, that are published.
They're in some ways,
though there's not mostly.
Of course these are private investments so
there might not necessarily be returns.
That are reported by
some of the companies or
funds that invest in these projects.
So some of that information,
privately held by companies of course, but
there are some industry publications
that publish data on, for example,
the funds that have been raised
to invest in infrastructure and
for some specific projects there is also
the public agency that procures
them might publish funding support.
So, for data like revenue
goes to investment returns.
>> It sounds like a lot of effort
needs to be invested up front
to create the detailed contract
considering they are federal stakeholders.
What about the overhead related
to enforcing the contract?
>> That's an excellent point so
using project
finance has higher transaction costs for
completing the procurement in both of
those costs that you mentioned in terms
of sorting out the project lifecycle plan,
essentially.
So there are additional transaction costs.
So when a government considers this
procurement model, essentially if you
break down the assessment
into its simplest form,
what they're doing is they're
essentially valuing the risk that
they're transferring to the private
partner And they're weighing that against
things like the added transaction
costs to complete the procurement.
Or if the project took the higher cost
of the capital using project finance,
which it should, they'll be weighing that.
So they're weighing some of their costs
against the risk that they're transferring
through the procurement.
The overhead to enforcing,
that's an additional cost as well.
In general,
most of these projects are procured using
a performance based contract.
But there's, so
most of the contracts that use this model
essentially permit the government
to conduct an inspection.
To make sure that maintenance
is being spent, or
require the contractor to regularly
report their maintenance activities.
So there are some costs there.
I think for a lot of these projects,
that cost in particular is relatively low,
but it really depends
on the project itself.
>> Okay great.
Even broader question here
from this participant.
What will be the optimal
GDP percentage of company,
I mean a country should
assign to its infrastructure?
>> Yeah [INAUDIBLE].
>> Take on that [LAUGH].
>> If you read academic literature
on infrastructure, there's a lot
of economists that have spilt a lot
of ink on that topic in particular.
It does vary widely.
There are some interesting studies
actually coming out of China now.
Mainly because China invests a much
higher percentage of its GDP
in local infrastructure than
really any developed economy.
And part of that is because
China's of course been rapidly
urbanizing over the last few decades.
But there you see as a percent of GDP,
I think it's getting up toward 8%,
whereas the US has been between two and
3% of GDP.
Personally, I don't think there's
necessarily a right answer.
I think a lot of the discourse
in academia or in public policy
has been about targeting that appropriate
percent of GDP invested in infrastructure.
When really infrastructure projects
really justify themselves based on their
microeconomics, not macroeconomics.
So, the specific impacts of
a particular project really need to be
assessed in order to be determined if it
is going to be economically beneficial.
But that at least might give
you a little bit of a range
in terms of the US which is kind of
on the low end between two and 3%.
Towards an outlier on the other
end of upwards of 7% GDP.
>> Okay, we have a participant
asking you to speak about P3 for
aging energy assets,
such as central plants.
>> Yeah, this is, so
project finance, I didn't,
my discussion today was really
focused on public infrastructure.
So transportation and
social infrastructure.
But for energy project finance
is actually been used in
the United States in Globally
at a much higher rate.
So for a P3 for an aging energy asset,
I think that the problem.
Or what would need to be
addressed in procurement is really
the source of funding for the project.
So if it's an aging infrastructure
asset that requires rehabilitation.
The government or sponsoring body for
that procurement would really have
to identify a funding source.
So that might be if it's
an electric utility it might
be part of its rate base or some other
source of funding for the asset.
So it certainly has potential but
really it comes down to identifying
that revenue stream for the project.
>> Do all public private partnerships
include allowing the private
entity to have infrastructure
that they can monetize?
If there are other options,
can you elaborate?
That's a lot of talking [LAUGH].
And we get a lot of questions so [LAUGH].
>> So in general the using project finance
all of the cost to develop an asset and
maintain it for
the long term are accounted for.
So I guess to answer your question,
using this procurement model
the project has to be fully funded.
And the private company
that wins the contract.
And also importantly the financer, the
source of debt financing for the project
is going to really scrutinize this
project to make sure it's fully funded.
So by that metric there
has to be a source of
actual funding for
a project that uses this model.
Maybe I could clarify just that
using this procurement
model in almost every case.
The private partner doesn't
get ownership of the infrastructure
asset to monetize it.
So, usually it'll just
be a long-term contract.
In some cases, there's privatization so
the asset will be transferred
in ownership to the contractor.
But most cases it's not.
But I guess to answer your question
yes there does have to be a source of
funding if project finance
was going to be used yeah.
>> What is the strongest case we
made the government has incentive to
keep infrastructure supply
in balance to demand?
How can I do so without the use of prices?
>> Yeah, that's an interesting question.
I mean, there is a whole industry in and
around estimating the economic
benefits of infrastructure development.
But that's obviously a part definitely.
There's a lot of science there, but
there's also a little bit of art in terms
of estimating the benefits to
a government of developing a new project.
It's difficult to tell.
You know I think for
some assets there can be pricing.
So I do think that's part of
the reason why projects that are funded
by a user fee as opposed to general taxes.
It might be a more efficient way of
generating funding for infrastructure
because the people that benefit from the
project are the people that pay for it.
Now I think,
there should also be general public
support or funding support for
infrastructure.
So projects shouldn't necessarily need to
be just using toll roads as an example.
They shouldn't necessarily only
need to be funded by tolls.
Because toll roads also
improve the economy.
And improve commute times.
I just to use this as an example, for
people that don't necessarily
drive on the toll road.
And so because of that, I think there's
definitely a case for general taxes.
But to get to your question
about the use of prices.
That's why a lot of economists recommended
user fee funding for toll roads or
other infrastructure because it does
give a direct indication of demand.
Do you have any examples of grid
modernization projects that use P3?
>> Yeah, so
this is a relatively new sector.
I would say, I don't have a very
good example in the United States
of a kind of grid modernization project.
There are some related projects.
So the state of Michigan recently procured
a contract to essentially
upgrade its lighting
systems on some freeways around Detroit.
So that would be the source of funding for
that project is essentially
the energy savings that the state's
going to have over the long term.
And I think that the city of Washington,
DC, is also in the process of
procuring a street lighting project.
Chicago has recently procured
a street lighting P3, so
I think that's kind of
a related grid upgrade or
pole upgrade project with a clear
source of funding through cost savings.
So that would be maybe a proxy.
>> Okay, how about elaborating on
infrastructure financing for energy,
especially distributed energy resources or
EV charging.
>> Yeah, so
I guess the trouble with more distributed
projects or EB charging projects for
cities, there have been some smaller
contracts to do that in the US.
In general I think those projects
to really use project finance or
to be procured as a public-private
partnership, they usually have to be
bundled because they're generally
kind of for smaller scale projects.
But the procurement model could
certainly be used for those.
I think for new technologies,
like sometimes this
procurement model,
it can be slower to be adopted.
So in this case,
if there's an EV contract or
kind of a I believe it was
a distributed energy kind of a project.
So the most likely source of
revenue there, of course,
will be energy fees from users of those EV
charging stations or from the community.
And so
because it's a relatively new sector,
it's kind of hard for
companies to really forecast that revenue.
So in some cases,
I would imagine for an EV project,
if a city wants to pursue one of those
using a public-private partnership,
they might be able to transfer some of
that demand risk to a private partner, but
also potentially guarantee some payment
over the long term for the project.
So it's possible, but it's difficult for
some new technologies to
really assess demand.
>> Looks like we have time for
about one more question.
Who is the right expert to
help develop legislation or
a ballot initiative to create an optimized
version of the Canada-Australia special
procurement authority to encourage P3s?
Seems like a good question to end on.
>> Yeah, so it's interesting,
I mean, there's lobbyists for
the infrastructure industry just like
there are lobbyists for every industry.
And there is certainly experts
that have kind of looked at
the US federal policy in ways
to incentivize some of these.
And so I think there's some expert groups
out there on infrastructure policy.
I guess one of the factors, of course,
is that the agencies I mentioned
aren't necessarily federal agencies,
although there have been some good
programs created like the Build America
Bureau at the federal government.
These are state level agencies, so
it's not necessarily DC that
requires some convincing.
But I think like those state
level agencies in Canada and
Australia, once they were formed and
they developed a track
record of operating history,
they really kind of took off from there.
So I think we'll see what happens with
our state level agencies here in the US.
And one of them might go out on a limb.
>> Great, with that we want to just
thank you so much for your time today.
We hope you enjoyed the hour and
encourage you to check out all of
our offerings at scpd.stanford.edu.
And again, don't forget you'll be
receiving a recording of this webinar to
share with your friends and colleagues.
Thanks so much for taking the time
to attend and have a great day.
>> Sure.